[Musique]
elles sonent le mal qui ronge notre
société les violences à l'intérieur des
familles brisent des vies et fracturent
les consciences un drame du quotidien
face auquel la justice se montre trop
souvent impuissante et parfois aveugle
et
[Musique]
sourde il y a 10 ans j'ai été internée
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique et
pendant un mois et après ma vie a
basculé nous sommes en 2010 dans le
couple du bois rien ne va plus ce 11
juin on sonne à la porte du pavillon
près d'Orléan où Valérie vit avec son
mari et ses deux enfants ils sont
arrivés il y avait des infirmiers et
puis des policiers et j'ai essayé de
discuter de m'expliquer mais ça n'a pas
fonctionner et donc le le policier il
m'a fait une prise il m'a mis les mains
dans le dos et il m'a mis les menottes
et puis m'a pter devant mes enfants
devant tout le voisinage en plein jour
au bout d'un mois après avoir été
examiné par deux psychiatres Valérie
Dubois est libérée son internement a été
orchestré par son mari et son médecin
sur la base d'un faux certificat médical
ils sont condamnés pour faux et usage de
faux 3 ans plus tard mais ent-temps et
malgré cette condamnation Valérie Dubois
a perdu la garde de ses enfants confiés
à son mari elle les verra une fois par
mois pendant 10 ans chistal a
aujourd'hui 23 ans elle vit avec sa mère
et s'exprime pour la première
fois j'ai pas du tout eu l'impression
d'avoir été entendu ben par la justice
et les
professionnels à chaque fois que j'ai pu
me confier chez eux ils ont retourné la
situation en disant que c'était ma mère
qui me forçait à à parler qui me forçait
à dire des choses et je me souviens bah
d'une fois où justement on était censé
voir une éducatrice spécialisé à qui
j'avais déballé tout ce qui n'allait pas
et comment je me sentais je lui avais
expliqué bah l'état dans lequel je me
suis retrouvée avec cette situation et
la seule chose qu'elle m'a dit elle m'a
dit que j'étais une enfant compliqué et
que c'est moi qui qui compliquait la
situation et que si en gros je me
faisais du mal bah c'était juste parce
que je cherchais à avoir de la
tenenstion et que juste qu'il fallait
que j'arrête parce que je faisais des
problèmes en plus donc au lieu de
m'aider au final
elle m'a juste
[Musique]
enfoncé c'est vrai que le fait d'avoir
été privé de mes enfants pendant ou une
longue période pratiquement 10 ans
grosso modo et bien ça a été difficile
ça a été très difficile et je dirais que
c'est littéralement inhumain c'est
inhumain c'est vraiment une torture et
je veux croire que derrière il n'y avait
pas de volonté de nuire mais vraiment un
dysfonctionnement en soi Marie France
Irigoyen est psychiatre elle a publié
plusieurs ouvrages sur les problèmes
intrafamiliaux et reçoit dans son
cabinet parisien de nombreux patients en
souffrance pris dans de longues
procédures dont ils ne comprennent pas
toujours le
sens pour le moment les juges font au
mieux mais n'ont pas les moyens de
rendre des décisions euh correcte en
particulier quand des il y a des quand
les décisions impliquent des enfant et
très clairement tout toute difficulté
euh tout ce qui est euh une décision qui
n'est pas bonne qui est pas rendue
suffisamment tôt aussi et est correcte a
un impact considérable sur les enfants
et c'est leur avenir en fait j'en parle
pas j'en parle pas parce que j'avais
honte
et je préférais montrer aux gens que
tout allait bien j'avais pas de
problème c'est une partie de moi que je
cache au fond de moi Valérie Dubois
aussi continue à payer les conséquences
de ce dysfonctionnement judiciaire
puisque son ex-mari ne lui a toujours
pas reversé sa part de leur maison
commune j'ai eu le sentiment que dans
cette affaire quoi que a pu dire ma
cliente elle aurait été inaudible et
qu'on s'est uniquement basé sur les
thèses sur les arguments de monsieur
Dubois qui vraisemblablement c'était
bien préparé beaucoup mieux préparé que
ma cliente et et donc ça lui a permis de
faire tous les dégâts qu' a commis étant
précisé que il y avait pas mal
d'éléments qu' qu'il avait apporté qui
étaient totalement mensongés totalement
faux en France les juges aux affaires
familiales les JAF ne reçoivent aucune
formation spécifique comme le déplore
Isabelle Rome magistrate ancienne
ministre chargée de l'égalité
hommes-femm c'est bien pour que tous les
magistrats qui est àire avec des
violences attra familiales soit formé
que a été annoncé donc par la la
première ministre dès le mois de mars
2023 la création de pôles spécialisé
dans chaque tribunal c'est-à-dire qu'on
aura des magistrats spécifiquement
formés et aussi avec une cohérence entre
les différents magistrats qui peuvent
intervenir pour que il n'y ait pas de
contrariété de
décision les attermoimement de la
justice en matière de violence
intrafamiliale Pauline Bourgouin c'est
son nom d'emprunt les éprouve depuis
plus d'un an depuis ce jeudi de janvier
2022 à Orléan qu'elle n'est pas prête
d'oublier alors un jour quand je
récupère ma fille à la crèche la
responsable me lance un regard qui me
terrifie en me disant il y a quelque
chose de grave il faut que je vous parle
et je reçois un message le soir qui
m'explique que ma fille tremble au
moment de chaque change avec chacune des
assistantes maternelles
c'est tout à fait anormal et qu'il a dû
se passer quelque chose et elle me
demande de parler avec ma fille pour
essayer d'en savoir plus
je je ne réalisais pas que il pouvait y
avoir de l'inceste derrière ça je
j'arrivais pas à me à le
concevoir l'inceste c'est le motif du
signalement effectué par la
pédopsychologue qui a reçu l'enfant
pauline est alors séparée du père de sa
petite fille après une relation
difficile qui a duré 3 ans
en mai 2022 sa vie bascule une deuxème
fois j'ai reçu un
appel cours duquel on m'a annoncé qu'ils
allaient demander le le placement en
famille d'accueil de ma fille et quand
j'ai demandé pourquoi quel était le
danger identifié chez moi
m'ont dit que j'étais trop à l'écoute de
ma fille et trop
bienveillante que le le trop n'était
jamais bon et et ell m'ont dit aussi que
ell se posait des questions sur mon ma
santé
mentale en janvier dernier après une
nouvelle décision de justice la petite
Louise est revenue vivre chez sa mère
qui a déménagé en banlieu parisienne
pour autant l'affaire est loin d'être
terminée bonjour
bonjour
alors les appels avec le père donc ça
comment ça se passe elle refuse toujours
alors les pour les trois derniers appels
elle s'est mise à faire une crise
d'angoisse et du coup le service social
a a reporté l'appel Pauline Bourgouin
encourt un an de prison pour non
présentation d'enfants à son excomagnon
qui conteste les faits qui lui sont
reproché malgré l'extrême gravité des
accusations la justice n'a toujours pas
statué définitivement sur l'autorité
parentale du père plus il y a des
éléments il y a la parole de l'enfant
laquelle peut être évalué de manière
tout à fait scientifique il faut juste
avoir des bons experts c'est un autre
sujet mais on a un vrai problème
d'expertise en France il y a évidemment
des symptômes qui coïncident avec les
paroles de
l'enfant vraiment systématiquement les
nuésies le la régression enfin tout tout
tous ces symptômes là l'enfant ne peut
les jouer et ils accompagnent les
déclarations le problème il est que la
justice ne veut pas aller voir ces
éléments ne veut pas entendre les
enfants ne veut pas croire leur mère et
préfère penser que ce sont les femmes
qui manipulent les enfants pour écarter
les pères et je crois que c'est contre
cette cette idée malheureusement très
présente et bah qu'il faut lutter de
plus en plus l'idée du principe de
précaution fait son chemin le juge aux
affaires familiales pourrait instaurer
une mesure de protection immédiate dans
les 24
heures je pense qu'il faut protéger
protéger protéger c'est-à-dire que quand
il y a des violences et bien il faut
oser prendre certaines décisions qui
peuvent paraître parfois peut-être un
peu radical mais je pense que il faut il
ne faut pas hésiter parfois à remettre
en cause l'autorité parentale du
conjoint violent remettre en cause sa
droit de visiter d'hébergement c'est
toute l'approche juridique psychologique
et sociale des violences intrafamiliales
qui est à
revoir moi je pense qu'il faudrait avant
tout qu'il y ait une sorte de
filtre dès le départ pour repérer la
dangerosité alors on a des grilles
d'évaluation du danger ça c'est dans les
commissariats et dans les gendarmeries
mais c'est pas suffisant il faudrait
qu'il y ait en quelque sorte une une
première expertise précoce pour repérer
les situations
inquiétantes pour pour l'autre conjoint
mais aussi pour les
[Musique]
enfants Pauline Bourgouin sait que son
combat ne fait que commencer aujourd'hui
elle est dans l'impossibilité de TR
travailler car les démarches liées à la
procédure sont complexes et demandent du
temps pour se déplacer dans les
différentes
[Musique]
juridictions aujourd'hui je peux pas
dire que j'ai confiance en la justice au
sens large en revanche je reste
consciente que derrière chaque décision
il y a des humains qu'on peut tomber sur
des humains qui sont très bien formés
qui font leur travail consciencieusement
et il a aussi de de tomber sur une autre
personne qui qui prendra moins temps ou
qui aura moins bien compris les enjeux
et et et de ce
fait j'aurais toujours une incertitude
et une certaine crainte de la
justice parfois aussi la justice peut
avoir un sentiment de fierté et ne pas
vouloir se dédire en quelque sorte pour
éviter de perdre la face y compris si ça
se fait au détriment du justiciable
parfois on a des clients qui ont peut
être condamnés à tort à des peintes
d'emprisonnement et souvent le juge vous
dira ou les magistrats plutôt en général
ou les membres les auxilires de justice
vous diront en coulisse qu'ils se sont
trompés mais ils n'uront pas le courage
de le faire publiquement pour éviter de
perdre la face et de ne plus être
[Musique]
crédible si on arrive dans un endroit où
le droit n'est pas pris en compte on ne
parle pas des textes de loi les les
pièces qu'on apporte ne sont pas prises
en considération euh les faits euh sont
occultés ce n'est plus un lieu où on
rend la justice mais ça devient un lieu
d'injustice en attendant les pôles
spécialisées annoncé par le ministre de
la Justice les affaires de violence
intrafamiliale continuent de s'entasser
sur le bureau des
magistrats